[Musique]
Monopoly vous y avez forcément joué ce
sont des classiques mais ça vous dit
quelque chose Katan Carcassonne savon
wonders ou pandémie ce sont les jeux dit
modernes et cela ils ont trouvé le grand
public un peu grâce au confinement mais
pas uniquement aujourd'hui jouer autour
d'une table à encore plus de sens
qu'avant le covid
plus de 300 jeux à disposition qui sont
rangés par
thématique de type de jeu et donc vous
avez une première armoire et de ce côté
là qui est plutôt sur les jeux de
confrontation quand on joue les uns
contre les autres vous avez les deux
armoires ici qui parlent de jeu plutôt
de gestion il y a donc le choix pour
cette soirée jeux organisée à
Saint-Jean-de-Braye par les bénévoles de
l'association le coffre à jeu
on va essayer de trouver d'autres
personnes les tables se forment en
fonction des envies de chacun un jeu de
stratégie ou plus coopératif près d'une
cinquantaine d'adhérents ce sont
déplacés ce soir pour passer une nuit
ludique soit ça soit propolis
qu'est-ce qui vous tente le plus moi
j'aime bien les deux je vais proposer
aux copains
je vais essayer de leur expliquer parce
que je suis connu pour faire des pour
faire des erreurs de règles mais
celui-là j'ai quand même joué pas mal de
fois donc
à chaque table en bénévole pour
expliquer les règles au novices
du bois vient d'arriver dans le jeu je
dis ça je dis rien
et pour Mireille c'est une première elle
découvre l'univers de Catane
du débutant au joueur aguerri il y en a
pour tous les goûts et tous les styles
je le joue et je vais augmenter la trade
mon zoo de 3 des parties de 5 heures à
celle de 30 minutes les joueurs se
retrouvent surtout pour passer une
soirée conviviale et ça fait 8 ans que
ça dure moi je suis arrivée ici il y a
un an en plein covid donc je connaissais
personne c'était vraiment une bonne
façon de rencontrer des gens et de
retrouver toutes les deux semaines des
gens sympas avec qui je sais que je
passe une bonne soirée de découvrir des
jeux ou de jouer avec à des jeux que
j'aime bien à plus que de si on joue
avec toujours avec le même groupe chez
soi on joue toujours de la même manière
là ça permet de d'avoir quelque chose de
différent c'est vrai que on a beaucoup
de jeux différents la coopération et
gestion c'est vrai qu'on découvre
beaucoup de choses et on passe de très
bonnes soirées jusqu'à 2h du matin c'est
très long mais on voit pas passer
l'engouement autour de ces soirées ne se
dément pas vient au contraire
jusqu'en 2019 ou on est arrivé à plus de
180 adhérents on a eu un gros Gap en
2020-2021 je suppose que vous imaginez
pourquoi et puis là on s'en reprend
petit à petit on remonte on est à 120
adhérents là mais avant 2020 on avait
vraiment une augmentation chaque année
après c'est c'est aussi aujourd'hui il y
a de plus en plus de d'associations qui
se créent dans le secteur donc il y a
des gens qui se dispersent un petit peu
entre guillemets donc c'est normal aussi
que ils viennent pas tous chez nous
association festivals barrages le
secteur du jeu de société fait Flores il
attire autant les joueurs que les
entreprises quatrième cours on arrête
quand on fait quoi
à toxiner en Touraine WDK spécialisée
dans la distribution de jouets s’est
lancée dans l'édition de jeux de société
en 2012 ici on reçoit des concepts de
jeux et les équipes marketing les
transforment
voilà le jeu en fait à l'origine
l'auteur
qui est issu du jeu concours justement
qu'on a réalisé chez WDK nom de code de
la quête des pirates des pirates on
passe aux aventuriers ses plus grand
public et pour l'illustration
l'entreprise a fait appel à un artiste
extérieur reste encore à trouver un
titre c'est important parce que c'est ce
qui interpelle aussi le consommateur
donc il faut que les images les couleurs
lui donnent envie d'acheter et le nom on
essaye toujours chez woodica de les
faire un petit peu drôle
si ce jeu peine à trouver un nom
d'autres boîtes ont déjà du succès thème
au totem est aussi un jeu issu du
concours WDK et là c'est en interne que
le design a été réalisé ce projet là ça
a duré environ trois mois mais vraiment
par rapport à aux différents éléments
qu'il y a et c'est vrai que c'est un jeu
où il y a un packaging il y a des cartes
il y a une notice aussi à réaliser donc
pas mal d'étapes aussi notamment de
création visuelle et esthétique pour
qu'on ait une esthétique vraiment idéale
qui correspondent à tout le monde
en se lançant dans l'édition de jeu la
société tourangelle WD renouvelle son
image et surf sur le succès des jeux de
société
c'est un vrai marché alors c'est vrai
que le coït accéléré les choses autour
du jeu de société ça a été vraiment très
fédérateur parce qu'en fait les familles
se sont retrouvées bloquées évidemment
chez elle et ont pu jouer profiter du
temps qu'elles avaient pour jouer
ensemble à des petits jeux de société
s'éloigner un peu des écrans et du
digital qui est voilà qui qui nomme le
marché donc c'est vrai que nous on avait
pris ce secret d’eau bien avant le covid
mais le covid a accéléré le mouvement et
ça a surtout valider notre
positionnement en disant voilà le parti
Gunt le petit jeu de famille en sachant
que notre aussi notre positionnement
c'est de créer des jeux qui sont très
simples à prendre en main et qui se
répartit rapides parce qu'on sait qu'on
a de moins en moins de temps
malheureusement et donc du coup les le
jeu il s'appréhendent deux trois minutes
c'est des règles simples et les parties
dure à peu près 10 minutes voilà donc
c'est aussi c'est vraiment dans l'air du
temps et c'est ce que les gens
recherchent aujourd'hui
un Châteauroux paria édition à pignons
sur rue les frères Rousseau ont créé
leur société d'édition pour pouvoir
publier leurs propres jeux du premier
prototype présenté en festival aux
produits actuels il s'est passé quatre
ans
on se rend pas compte mais on en a fait
du chemin on est passé par pas mal de
galères et comme j'ai tendance à pas mal
documenter en fait
et les galères et les bonnes choses qui
passent chez tendance à bien sentir le
temps qui passe et là j'ai l'impression
4 ans ça fait 10 points c'est vrai que
c'est très particulier de revoir un truc
qu'on a pas ouvert depuis longtemps il y
avait même la photo de nous à l'époque
où j'avais les cheveux ici ça si ça
c'est pas collector
et sans se départir de leur idée
d'origine les frères Rousseau ont réussi
à produire le jeu qu'il voulait pour eux
être auteur ce n'est pas le plus
difficile c'est vouloir éditer le jeu
qui a été un vrai défi
hauteur quand il va potentiellement
vendre son jeu ou son idée à un éditeur
il va toucher entre 5 et 8% du prix de
vente hors taxes de l'éditeur par
exemple notre jeu qui vendu 60 euros en
boutique on peut faire les maths 50
euros si on enlève le 20% de TVA on
passe à en gros 25 € à la boutique à
acheter pour pouvoir la revendre L50
l'éditeur l'a donc acheté quelque chose
comme bruit 17 et 18 euros
à l'éditeur et donc en fait 5 à 8% des
17 à 18 euros en gros de l'éditeur ce
qui veut dire qu'il faut vendre
énormément de jeux ce qui si je suis à
peu près bon en maths doit faire 90
centimes par jeu vendu pour un auteur
donc à moins qu'on en vende 50000 on
fait difficilement de l'argent et la
plupart des jeux c'est 2-3000
exemplaires donc en fait l'auteur il
fait ça quasiment tout le temps à perte
et c'est pour gagner leur vie qu'ils
aient dite et distribuent eux-mêmes les
jeux qu'ils ont conçus et quand on leur
demande pourquoi Châteauroux je préfère
être le seul la seule maison d'édition
dans un endroit où il n'y en a pas
plutôt qu'être par exemple à Paris où je
serai une maison d'édition parmi 50
autres voilà donc je me démarque ne
serait par ça et je suis né ici j'adore
cet endroit et il y a une volonté de
dynamiser en fait le l'endroit le lieu à
Châteauroux donc il y a énormément
d'aide énormément de contacts énormément
de réseaux qui sont faits parce que les
gens disent bah ce que vous faites c'est
bien et c'est important de continuer à
le pousser
aujourd'hui le deuxième chapitre de
l'ordre de VL vient de sortir et
d'autres jeux pour un public plus novice
devrait voir le jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était la dernière de leur émission
trick track show fin décembre
bonjour à tous est-ce que vous allez
bien
en public pour la première fois les
équipes Tric Trac tirent leur révérence
leur émission hebdomadaire sélectionnez
les jeux parmi plus de 1000 références
sortant chaque année et on va donc
pouvoir accueillir nos premiers invités
le seul lieu de référencement et de
critiques du jeu de société en France un
pionnier qui le restera longtemps le
rachat par asmode en 2018 plus gros
éditeurs de jeux de société dans
l'Hexagone n'a pas suffi face à la
concurrence d'autres sites
tour des ennemis déplacés chaque affreux
qui ne se trouve pas déjà sur la case
d'un family de un point de déplacement
vers le familier le plus proche
on
leur reste de jeu pour
l'enjeu qui sont gérés par nous c'est la
malchance et la contrariété dans le jeu
je vais apprendre à être à être avec les
autres je vais apprendre à être avec
moi-même me découvrir en disant ah mais
non mais là dans ce jeu là on m'a trahi
en fait je supporte absolument pas et
pourtant je ne risque rien je ne risque
au pire que de perdre la partie mais oui
et alors enfin je veux dire on peut
perdre bien plus que ça dans la vie donc
le jeu de toute façon est un milieu dans
lequel on peut expérimenter mille et une
chose à propos de soi et à propos des
autres le sabre je vais continuer encore
un peu pour monsieur Guillaume membre
Tric Trac de la première heure le
renouveau du jeu de plateau reste une
bonne nouvelle
cette ouverture sur le grand public ne
se dément pas c'est à dire que les
grands classiques sont en passe d'être
entérinés voilà les nouveaux classiques
seven Wonder pandémie etc dixit sont des
jeux dont de plus en plus de gens
entendent parler ou voir même ont déjà
joué et ça c'est toujours le cas par
contre il faut quand même noter une
chose c'est que contrairement aux jeux
vidéos par exemple qui a connu des
années avec une croissance positive et
négative en dent de si même si les
choses continuent fort bien se passer le
jeu de société est un secteur qui lui
n'a cessé de croître quoi qu'il en soit
on a cru que la liseuse allait tuer le
livre on a cru que le jeu vidéo allait
tuer le jeu de société et non au final
le jeu vidéo est comme je l'ai dit dans
son histoire et le jeu de société ce
sont inter enrichis
fin de partie pour Tric Trac mais pas
pour l'engouement autour du jeu de
société les gens ne pouvons pas toucher
la recueil il y a actuellement les
brigands qui sont
dessus le renouveau du jeu moderne c'est
surtout le public adulte qu'il la porte
en faisant remonter les ventes se
rencontrer autour d'une table et d'un
plateau le temps d'une soirée avec ses
amis ce n'est plus ringard au contraire
c'est l'occasion de retrouver un peu de
lien un peu de contact et d'échanges
après des années à distance